the question that the people of our
country are now asking is this
and me and my family better off after 13
years of conservative government
the answer is no and as the IMF show
today it doesn't have to be this way
now I'm sure the minister will clutch at
straws and say everything is fine or the
IMF forecasts are just wrong
but can he explain why the UK is still
the only G7 economy that is smaller now
than it was before the pandemic why is
the UK the only G7 economy with its
growth forecast downgraded this year
why are we at the bottom of the league
table both this year and next year too
and can the minister answer this
why should anyone trust the
conservatives with the economy ever
again